hello dr. Burke here in this video we're
going to talk about peripheral
neuropathy now we're going to relate
this to diabetes there's other
conditions that you can have it as well
but what is it basically the sensation
of pain burning pain numbness numbness
and tingling or any combination thereof
on your hands or your feet okay and so
what happens in diabetes it's one of the
symptoms that you want to watch out for
when you start experiencing that it's
starting to advance a little bit too
deep in the body now the reason why it's
affecting the hands and the feet first
is simply because those nerves are the
longest so if you envision having this
tube of carrying oxygen and nutrition
the very end of that tube is going to
experience the deficiency burst right
because it has to go all the way over
there same thing with the hands in the
feet now what causes this is the high
levels of sugar in the blood causing
micro vascular injury the body does not
like too much sugar it's toxic so it
creates very small arterial or vascular
injury to the nervous system so the
blood vessels that feed the nerves
get disrupted okay that's number one
number two glycated end-products now
what is that that's just another
mechanism that you have this protein
that's building up because the high
sugar on the nerves stopping the flow of
nerve impulses okay number three vitamin
b12 deficiency or vitamin b1 deficiency
okay both of those vitamins control the
synthesis of mild in around the nerve
myelin is the kind of the fat insulator
of the nerve just like if you had a wire
you have this plastic or rubber
insulation myelin is the fat insulation
around the nerve well if you don't have
the b12 or the b1 you're not going to
make the insulation so that's going to
go away so you're going to start
short-circuiting that electrical flow
and start getting all sorts of nerve
issues okay so now what is the solution
well number one you've got to fix the
sugar problem which is an insulin
problem I'm going to put some links down
below and secondly you
need to start taking b12 and b1 I would
get those in a fat soluble form in
addition to that you want to also
consume nutritional yeast because
diabetics or people that are
pre-diabetics tend to always have
deficiencies of these two vitamins and a
lot of other ones so you need a little
bit more nutritional yeast you can get
it from any health food store all right
thanks for watching hey if you haven't
already subscribed press this little
button down below okay thanks